freaking Ron vitello he's the former
acting ice director under President
Trump and former border patrol Chief
under President Obama uh you know Ron I
want to get into what the difference
here is between title 42 which is at
some point going away and now title
eight that's the authority that'll be
left that they'll be using at the border
what's the difference and why is title
42 so much easier to expel people with
well thanks for having me on title 42 is
in U.S code it's regards public health
and so it allows HHS delegated to the
DHS Frontline employees can expel people
regardless of their circumstance at our
Southwest border back into Mexico to
protect us all from pandemic conditions
uh it's always going to Sunset it was
always based on what the pandemic was
doing now challenged in court to be
ended and what it does is it allows the
board of Patrol to quickly adjudicate
those that qualify for expulsion so
maybe a half hour to adjudicate somebody
to expel them back once they end title
42 whether by the court or some other
method then Title VII is the criminal
code that allows Frontline employees to
arrest uh and and prosecute people who
come into the border to come across the
border illegally they're not going to do
that because they're so far overwhelmed
once title 42 comes down they'll be
busier than they are now both in volume
of people of coming and in the workflow
what used to take a half hour is to
adjudicate is now going to require them
about about two to three hours to
adjudicate so it's a bit about the
workflow but title 42 would not be an
issue if this Administration followed
the law it is a federal crime to cross
the border illegally and make a specious
claim for asylum in the United States
they had tools when they took over
this presidency with the migrant
protection protocols that allowed people
to have their due process allow them to
have their Asylum claims but wait in
Mexico instead and because of that we
had 40-year lows inactivity on our
Southwest border this Administration is
flouting federal law they refuse to
prosecute they refused to put policies
in place that they know will work and in
fact tore down policies that were
working and now we're seeing it in real
time well you're seeing it in a number
of cities really over the last several
weeks it's been El Paso take a look at
what El Paso says it's been spending
9.87 million dollars this year trying to
do with it New York City's mayor says he
needs a billion dollars to help deal
with all of this the Congress passed in
the Omnibus several hundred million
dollars to help communities
receive a lot of these migrants
humanitarian assistance is that enough
it's not these cities are not equipped
for that the border is not equipped the
DHS facilities are not equipped what
they needed to do is enforce the
policies that existed before that bill
should have had conditions for that
money yeah okay let's give them the
relief let's give those communities that
we're not allowed to plan for this
nonsense let's let's help them with some
resources but let's put policies in
place that help us control that border
let's give the tools that the men and
women of DHS need to control that border
that's what needs to happen this is what
we get with a president who cares
nothing about the Southwest border
you worked in this in the last two you
worked in the last two Democratic
administrations as well what is the big
difference between the Obama
Administration and the Biden
Administration on this issue
that's an interesting question I was a
career employee for most of my career
except for that last nine months under
the Trump Administration Obama didn't
believe in enforcing the Border either
uh they just hit it better this
Administration has openly called for an
open border and you can see here's an
example they're they're blaming Governor
Abbott for what happened over the
weekend sending a bus to the Naval
Observatory but they don't say anything
about tens of thousands of people
crossing the border in the same weekend
in El Paso oh and then by the way they
took the State of Arizona to court
because they had the gall to put border
barriers on the Southwest border to help
control the flow across the border of
illegal aliens in Arizona so we know
where this Administration stands and
this is what we get with Democratic
control and weakness in this Omnibus
Bill and not helping the front line
solve this problem Ron vitello thanks so
much for joining us this afternoon
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else